hello everyone and welcome to game three
of their semi-final match in the opera
euro rapid it's magnus carlson versus
maxime rashel lagrave
and in game two uh magnus almost got his
second win but then he overlooked uh
the exchange and maxine was able to draw
that game and now again
magnus with the white pieces and again
maxime goes for his uh groomfield
defense and
let's see what happens this time as uh
it seems to always go well first i
thought
i'm not going to cover this game then
when i saw what what was happening i
thought oh yeah i'm definitely covering
this game then i was like
nope not covering this game and then
well
you'll see so uh magnus with the white
pieces again
opens with d4 uh we have knight to f6
c4 and g6 we have knight to c3 and the
d5 the groomfield defenses on the board
but this time magnus doesn't go for
bishop to d2 as he's probably expecting
maxime
to have looked up some of the variations
that were played in game one so here he
switches it up
and goes uh into the uh sorry first
characters captures captures
uh and now e4 so just uh challenging the
knight without this bishop to d2
uh in between move knight captures b
captures and bishop to g7 now
so just the normal exchange variation we
have queen to a4 with
check and again queen to d7 and we have
an early queen trade we have catrice
captures and
now rook to b1 going after the b7 pawn
so here b6 and the disposition has been
reached before bishop to d3 is an old
move bishop c4 is a known move
uh but in the game magnus goes for f4
uh he grabs this center massively here
and
it is as of move tended we have a
completely new game
so let's see how uh maxime deals with
this uh of course
as you would when you play the
groomfield you play c5 you attack white
center that's why the bishop is on g7 uh
we have knight to f3 defending
and now bishop to c6 putting pressure uh
i'm calls and z for pawn we have bishop
to d3
defending uh you can't go d5 because
bishop captures on c3 comes with
check so bishop to d3 and now knight to
d7
just continuing development we have king
to e2 and now
e6 so here we have bishop to e3
again just continuing development and
now another
uh usual idea sd for pawn is under
attack just c4 you try to trade your c
font now c pawn for white's central e
for pawn of course
magnus doesn't allow that he goes bishop
back to c2
and now knight to f6 with a double
attack on the e4 pawn
uh we have knight to d2 defending uh and
now comes b5 as the c4 pawn was also
kind of under attack
and now that the pawn has been advanced
so far uh magnus attacks it with a4
and you cannot uh capture the pawn if
you capture it just rook a1
uh then the pawn will uh be easily one
and then you just ruin your pawn
structure on the queen side for nothing
so here after a4 we have a6 just
defending that
and now only now d5 a very interesting
idea by magnus
because it seems like uh what what are
you doing i mean uh black can just
capture that but after e
cap e captures on d5 magnus pushes e5
and now we have this
very uh very interesting position that
maxine probably hasn't encountered
before he did spend some time here
and in the end he went for knight to e4
which doesn't uh seem to be like the
uh the absolute best way uh to go about
it uh knight to g for sims
seems to be the best idea but then you
have to meet bishop to c5 preventing
black from castling and he didn't want
to meet that
probably king to d7 just keeping the
king at the center of the board and then
developing the rooks but instead
he goes knight to e4 and now puts
pressure on the c3 pawn this would come
with check and he would pick up the rook
so here magnus just grabs it
we have knight captures pawn captures
and rook h to d1 now grabbing hold of
the open d
file and here maxim finally castles
uh and now as uh magnus is the one
currently controlling the default he
goes for this very nice rook lift
uh attacking the bishop and maxine
defensive rook eight the c8 uh with a
capture swans a captures and now
uh you might be expecting rook to d1 or
rook to a1 just
either doubling up or putting the rook
on a nice open a file but magnus does
none of that he actually goes for the
exchange sacrifice
and plays rook captures in c6 and he
will grab two pawns while he's at it so
definitely worth it uh he will play
against two rooks but he will have the
bishop
pair so rook captures and now comes
bishop captures an e4 this is great
because it comes with an attack on the
rook
and you cannot defend this pawn the
bishop covers all of the dark squares
so here rook the a6 and now rook
captures on b5
uh we have rooked a d8 and now comes
rook to c5
getting the rook to attack the c pawn as
well rook to a4
defending and now king to f3 uh we have
bishop to f8 by maxim
challenging the rook uh forcing the rook
to move away and now
rook to c7 and now magnus will try to
get his
light square bishop into the attack
somehow you want to go after this
f7 pawn so i will we'll see uh if he can
maybe
uh get it in there somewhere somewhat
like this or maybe f5 will be an idea so
all depends on what maxine plays
so here bishop to a3 maxim uh this
bishop was doing nothing there and he
wants to play bishop to b2 and grab this
c3 pawn so magnus says all right you go
after that i'm just going to play f5 and
now you do not want to allow f6
if f6 happens then the king is just
stuck there you constantly have to worry
about
your back rank weaknesses so g captures
we have bishop captures
and now and now you have to feel that
you are in danger
uh rook to a5 has to be played uh for
specific reasons
rook to a6 also a possibility but here
maxine played bishop to b2
and now he simply allows a very simple
pawn push by magnus which magnus played
pretty much
uh very quickly uh he played e6 and now
what do you do
if you capture then the h7 pawn falls
but if you don't capture
uh there's not much you can do here rook
can capture an f7 punk and capture on f7
you have to worry about all sorts of
ideas here even e7 is an idea in some
lines
so uh maxime captures but now comes
bishop captures on e6 king the h8
if you go to king 2fa then it's just a
very quick checkmate bishop h6 check
king 8 and bishop f7 checkmate
uh the king has nowhere to go the rook
is covering the seventh rank the bishop
covers the fate and this
is defended so instead after uh bishop
captures with check king the h8 is
played
but now uh uh feel free to pause the
video
and win the game for magnus there is
only one winning move here so
uh you know be careful while i give you
a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
not delivering check with the bishop and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's
uh rook the c8 and after this rook the
c8 move there is nothing black can do
uh this is just a game over a point is
if the rook is captured
then just bishop to d4 is checkmate uh
the king has nowhere to go
and if you don't do this there's nothing
much to be done you're gonna lose an
entire rook here and even if you play
something like rook 8 to defend your
rook
the bishop to d4 check is still
checkmate because this rook is now
pinned
so very very tricky move this rook the
c8 idea because even magnus missed it
magnus played bishop to d for check
right away and
uh uh maxime now only has one move and
it's a great move
uh rook captures on the four pawn
captures and bishop captures he gives
back the exchange
he picks up a pawn and he's very happy
now he survived checkmate and he's now
uh still fighting it's an endgame of
opposite colored bishops
so here uh bishop to f5 going after the
h7 pawn
and now the defended maxim has to give
up the c4 pawn so rook to a7
now guards this square and now comes
rook captures on c4 magnus grabs another
pawn
but now he's only up one pawn and it's
opposite color bishop's not
not a lot you can do here but you can
try and uh you know bleed your opponent
dry uh it is it is a rapid game so why
not try with bishop to f6
and now h4 magnets will start pushing
those king side pawns king g7
we have king to g4 uh we have bishop to
e7 maxim just has to wait until
magnus pushes those pawns all the way
and then he's going to blockade them
king to h5 and now rook to a5 attacking
the bishop here
so g4 defending and now rook back to a7
uh we have rooked the c6 by magnus and
now bishop to f8 again
a nice waiting move waiting to see what
magnus does g5 by magnus and now
rook to b7 again another waiting move
with the ship the c2
uh and now comes uh bishop to b4 so
asking what what is your plan we have
king to g4 preparing to continue pushing
those pawns
and now bishop to d2 uh the the rook
should never really move
from the seventh rank because then you
allow check pick up the pawn
and so on so that rook is pretty much
stuck there so rook to h6 going after
the pawn this way but now the king just
moves king g8
and the pawn is sufficiently protected
uh we have rook to d6 attacking the
bishop and the bishop to c1 now
we have bishop to e4 by magnus attacking
the rook
uh and here we have rook to c7 and rook
to c7 is a pretty big mistake the rook
must remain uh
not only on the seventh rank but also if
you can to do that
you have to at least play rook to b4 and
pin this bishop and then
once you force the king out then you
continue checking the white king
however here after bishop to e4 uh rook
to c7 was played but now
magnus has a very very cool idea he
instantly plays
rook to d8 with check and now the
problem is uh well
none of the none of the moves work
because you have to move away from the
defense of the pawn
and once magnus grabs that it's just uh
two extra connected pawns it's it's game
over
so to show you what happens if the king
actually defends the pawn king to g7
uh you tell me what happens feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
only winning idea for white here while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
uh you know going for that uh you know
a precise mating net and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show the
only winning move is bishop to d5
so congratulations to everyone who found
that because now
you can see that there is nothing you
can do uh rook the
g8 is coming and all of the squares are
covered this is covered by the pawn this
is covered by the bishop and this will
be covered by the rook so rook the g8
will in fact be checkmate there are no
good moves here for black
you could only play something like rook
here to give up the exchange
as now you are guarding the g8 square
from the bishop uh but
just captures captures and now it's rook
against the bishop and the white is up
upon this is easily winning
so instead after this rook the d8 check
maxim saw that this
isn't working because of this so he
played the king to f7
but here magnus just played bishop
captures on h7
and he was in this position on move 50
that maxine rashelagh
resigned the game as now he's down two
points and of course he or
he knows very well that magnus will win
this
very easily uh so yeah magnus wins game
one uh game two uh
ended in a draw even though magnus was
pushing for the win and the game three
ends by magnus winning so will not
be even seeing game four as magnus
already won the match so very very
exciting stuff
but he also won the match like that uh
against double and then dubo retaliated
on the second day so magnus has to be
very careful
maxine will uh play play very very
aggressive
tomorrow i i imagine uh but as far as
the groomfield goes it's uh
uh it's uh two to zero uh in carlson's
favor
so not yet a a victory for for maximum
groomfield i don't actually know if
uh maxime ever got gotta win in
groomfield against magnus
uh but i will check uh so uh yeah
i i will mention it in the next video uh
so yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it
i will check up on the other match uh uh
tomorrow morning so we're gonna check
out some of the games from that
uh i would like to thank uh michael
zakarias will cannon tom roberts mark
[ __ ]
and uh uh pratamesh mahajan for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the uh of
this very nice rapid tournament checking
up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens uh in the
chess world so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day